I asked the question
how many of you
today are concerned there's a for the
first time in your career a genuine
possibility of a nuclear war
in January it would have been about one
percent and they would have thought it
would occur if only if Isis got a hold
of a nuclear weapon or an accident
occurred
folks
this breaking down of the international
and National norms
is the glue that holds the liberal world
order together
and holds together our system
that is what is being attacked now and
that's what's most dangerous
the urban report it's October 4th 2022
we are live streaming on Rumble YouTube
and Blaze TV subscribe share like all of
that stuff if you have not done so
already and I wanted to throw to that
cold open there because that's Joe Biden
obviously a couple years back you can
see even just from what you know two two
and a half years ago the guy was a
little bit sharper wasn't that sharp
then but was a little bit certainly a
little bit sharper than he is now uh and
he was warning about nuclear war because
of course orange man was president and
he was very mean and all sorts of stuff
we had four years of Peace under him and
this Ukraine Russia Russia thing right
now is really heating up between the
Nord stream pipeline blowing up in four
sections and then yesterday there were
rumors that Russia was maybe moving some
nuclear weapons that sounds like it's
not true but there's this weird thing
happening in the world right now and
this is of course to the backdrop of
this election that we've got coming up
here where you just never know what's
going to happen right before an election
where it seems like the war is getting
hot again that Russia is losing and it's
like well okay if the guy with the nukes
is losing and you don't give the guy
with the nukes an off-ramp a way to save
face a way to get out and not feel like
he's been totally destroyed or he's
going to be killed well then he's got
those weapons and that could be a
problem so I thought that would be an
interesting backdrop although it's
actually not what we're discussing today
today we are discussing that the vice
president is a racist and a communist
and her media cohorts are woke buffoons
and we Must Destroy them that is my work
for today
I've set out an agenda and I'm going to
stick to it all right so okay first the
way I thought we'd start this thing off
was there was a video about two three
weeks ago uh on real time Bill Mars uh
show oh and by the way a lot of you are
asking uh the interview that I did on
Bill Maher's podcast Club random it's
over a two hour conversation there's a
picture from last week we drank I smoked
some weed we talked about literally
everything some things that I wasn't
thrilled to talk about we talk about
everything the full
two hour podcast will be out on Sunday
October 9th that's this Sunday there'll
be Clips going across YouTube and
everything else and then once it's out
then I'll do a little more of my
feelings about it and a little bit of
analysis and all of that stuff but
as you guys know although bill and I we
probably started at a very very similar
say an old school classical liberal
position we've sort of diverged a little
bit that's okay that's kind of what we
got into of course but Bill is trying uh
to keep the Democrats sane it doesn't
seem to be working to me but he is
trying and I think it's a worthwhile
goal to try uh here's a video from about
two weeks ago where he basically is just
like man the Democrats have just
absolutely lost their minds this article
is called separating Sports by sex
doesn't make sense
yes it does
and this is the problem with the
Democrats
they are the party of no common sense
this article maintaining this binary in
Youth Sports maintaining this binary
meaning boys and girls on different
teams when they're young reinforces the
idea that boys are inherently bigger
faster and stronger
they are
this is
a notion that's been challenged by
scientists for years no it doesn't and
these are like these are the follow the
science people yeah
follow the science
okay credit where credit is due he gets
it he understands there's differences
between boys and girls he understands
that these people are not the ones that
are following the science even though
they're always screaming that we're
anti-science and all of that stuff the
question of course remains at the end of
the day which way are you going to vote
are you going to vote for more people
that will push these bad ideas and and
insert more wokeness into the government
and our cultural institutions and all
those things or are you going to kind of
suck it up and vote for some people that
maybe you disagree with on a couple
things but are actually pushing back
against that
you know my feelings on that let's leave
that there three days ago on real time
uh Bill uh wasn't too thrilled with
Kamala Harris and let it be known no I
mean he waited a very long time he's
like Dracula I have crossed oceans of
time
oceans of time to be the president once
you have that real estate and you wake
up in the White House and your office is
the oval I just don't think you'll give
it up it's very hard to take the
nomination away from the president
uh assuming president and what I could
see is replacing the vice president
because
yeah she's she's just not very popular
anywhere and it didn't seem to work out
and
um I don't know that's been done before
on a ticket I just think she's a bad
politician
I mean that's super interesting right
first off Bill basically says replace
her his audience claps right now his
audience which is a combination of say
let's say progressives and you know not
insane liberals something like that they
applaud that she should be replaced uh
Bill's argument I think still is that
Joe is either able to run or should run
or will run I I disagree with that I
just think there's absolutely no chance
they're gonna have to drag his rotting
carcass out there in two years from now
to do that and I think they're going to
throw him under the bus after the
midterms anyway but the point is he's
addressing the fact that Kamala Harris
is not very good at her job she was
polling incredibly low uh when he
selected her or when the powers that be
selected her and it's not working her
circular logic Russia big Ukraine small
going to North Korea going to South
Korea thinking she's in North Korea like
all of these things they start adding up
over time and then of course there was
this one from a couple days ago
obviously we had hurricane Ian here in
Florida and the devastation is still
being and cleaned up all over Southwest
Florida right now Kamala Harris went for
an interview on C-Span and she came out
in essence I mean she already was but
she went full racist and full communist
here is the unedited video unedited can
I say it's unedited this is the unedited
video
can you talk just a little bit about the
relief efforts obviously of a hurricane
in and what the administration has been
doing to address the climate crisis in
the states it is our lowest income
communities and our communities of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions and and impacted by by issues
that are not of their own making and so
I mean
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place and if we want people to
be in an equal Place sometimes we have
to take into account those disparities
okay so I know I played this one for you
yesterday but the brouhaha around it is
really what I want to address today but
very quickly first what she said there
at the end let's let's do the Communist
part first she wants everyone to end up
in the same place that is not congruent
with the American dream what the
American dream says is hey we've got
equality and some people start with more
some people start with less less some
people have great gifts some people
don't some people come from great
families some people come from broken
families there there's the Gestalt of
life that is uh just out there and if we
have equal laws for everyone it might be
harder for some people and easier for
some but plenty of people are born rich
and end up poor and plenty of people are
born poor and end up rich it's the
chance you got a chance man in the
United States that's what it's all about
the idea that you'd want all people to
end up in the same place uh no you
wouldn't want all people to end up in
the same place that is what communism is
that we would all have the same thing
now of course what she really means by
this she doesn't really mean it right
she doesn't really mean we'll all end up
in the same place she means her and her
crew of Elites they all have a lot more
but you peons will all end up just
satiated enough that you'll all have the
exact same thing so it's it's a
communist argument that she is making by
the way she was making that argument
before she was vice president it so at
least she's being consistent in her uh
in her interest in communism as far as
the racist part uh if you are going to
give government Aid by the basis of
someone's skin color she says you would
want Equity when it comes to communities
of color well if you're going to say oh
there's a trailer park of people and
their houses got blown away and here's
another trailer park of people and their
houses got blown away this community has
more black people this community has
more white people we're going to give
more resources here because of historic
Injustice or something then that is a
racist policy that is against the
Constitution of the United States so I
would actually welcome her to try to do
it
of course she won't try to do it because
the FEMA head already had to rebuke her
and say no we actually give Aid based on
whoever needs it it's as simple as that
but now here's why I'm reiterating this
whole point and bringing it up because
we did discuss it yesterday if you want
to see how the media and the political
Elite lie about everything and how they
launder their lies through the system
this is absolutely perfect so here's a
tweet by Andrew Bates now Andrew Bates
is the Deputy press secretary to the
White House I think he works right under
Corinne Jean-Pierre she's the press
secretary he's the deputy press
secretary so he quotes PolitiFact and
the New York Times and Reuters all
claiming that she did not say what we
just heard her say that it had something
to do with race uh PolitiFact no Kamala
Harris didn't say Hurricane Relief would
be based on skin color actually she did
we just played you guys the video I
should illustrate by the way or I should
just make a point of saying uh when I
told you that video wasn't edited we
just cut from the question immediately
to the answer so there was an edit there
but we didn't edit it for content in any
way you heard her ask about hurricane
Ian relief and then you heard the answer
to it so first go back to the Tweet
there for a second uh so there's he
quotes politifacts So PolitiFact Is a
website that lies they claim to be a
fact checking site but they lie because
she did say it would be based on skin
color she said communities of color then
he quotes the New York Times
conservatives distort Harris's remarks
about Hurricane Relief so it's ah you
see those conservatives they pounced
those mean conservatives nobody
distorted it she's the one that said
Equity should be built in and she's the
one who brought up skin color go back to
it one more time then Reuters
deliberately distorted we played it for
you straight up you know what relief
efforts obviously of a hurricane in and
what the administration has been doing
to address the climate crisis in the
states it is our lowest income
communities and our communities of color
that are most impacted by these extreme
conditions and and impacted by by issues
that are not of their own making and so
we
absolutely and so we have to address
this in a way that is about giving
resources based on Equity understanding
that we we fight for equality but we
also need to fight for Equity
understanding not everyone starts out at
the same place and if we want people to
be in an equal Place sometimes we have
to take into account those disparities
God it's worse every time you hear it
yeah not everyone does start in the same
place but it doesn't mean everyone
should end up in the same place she
she's anti-American she she doesn't
understand the American dream I believe
her to be racist and okay is what it is
so I showed you uh the deputy press
secretary for the White House using
mainstream media sources New York Times
PolitiFact and Reuters to lie right and
then a whole bunch of people myself
included we just tweet the video at him
and then they don't delete anything they
don't respond like they they don't mind
the lies because they know that they're
part of the machine so a day or two goes
by and everyone forgets uh BP Kamala
Harris's uh comes person Kirsten Allen
is her name she tweeted this Scott
Harris claimed said if you have a
different skin color you're going to get
relief faster after Hurricane Ian Harris
said no such thing we rate this claim as
false this is PolitiFact uh talking
about the exact same thing they were
referencing the Scot that they're
referencing there is Rick Scott who
Loosely quoted what Kamala Harris said
so you guys get it they lie and they lie
and they lie they're allowed to share
misinformation that is gov those are
government officials sharing
misinformation despite video that just
makes it so obvious what the truth is
and this actually when you understand
that they're anti-American and that they
have racist ideas and that they don't
mind lying and they have the whole
Machinery behind them this is also
directly linked to why they want to make
sure the rest of us are censored because
in the old days if you own the entire
cultural apparatus and the political
machinery
and all of it you could just lie and
nobody had we didn't have ways to to
debunk the lies in real time right but
now what happens on Twitter when these
people lie I mean both of those tweets
one from a deputy White House Press
Secretary and one from the comms girl
for the for the VP they get ratioed to
high hell because tons of people share
the video say no you're lying as I said
they don't delete it they don't
acknowledge that they're doing it that
they're lying in the first place so what
that does lead to is that's why big Tech
must censor us that's because they know
that too many people can see the truth
so whether it's suppressing certain
things or Banning certain people or
making it so that one side can't share
misinformation but one one side can you
guys get it so that's why there is such
a toxic stew here it's also why I always
say you have to give the devil is due
because whether it's starting a freaking
nuclear war a week before the the
midterms or just lying about all of
these things or bringing back covert or
whatever it's like we gotta don't don't
feel so great right now yes it does look
and by any sane logic there will be a
red wave but don't get overconfident
ma'am because these people will pull out
every trick in the book and they will
claim that you are the ones doing it
while they do it right in front of your
face but the point of all of this is
that her Equity comments are reflective
of what Democrats think of minorities
they think that minorities are helpless
and they think that minorities whether
it's a sexual minority uh whether it is
a skin color minority whatever it might
be they need you in that box they got
nothing else so they will Pander to high
hell to keep you in your box and and
keep you really so that you're not a
person what they fear is the individual
more than anything else and uh
unfortunately for them the individual is
the root of our free western Society so
they use this racial division this
negativity basically as a battering ram
to advance their agenda which of course
is government control over everything so
now I want to move forward a little bit
because I really thought this was
wonderful you guys know Amela epinobi
who's been on the show many times she's
a contributor at prageru she's a good
friend of mine she's she's become just
an absolute All-Star in fighting this
woke nonsense she went on Dr Phil and uh
debated with a professor from Arizona
State his name is Neil Lester on
cultural appropriation and I just
thought this was wonderful so it is a
thing and people need to be aware of can
anybody appropriate
uh anybody can appropriate yes not just
white people uh absolutely appropriation
is intersectional so old people can
appropriate youth culture youth culture
can appropriate old folks uh people who
are not incarcerated can impersonate you
know prisoners or those are incarcerated
uh men appropriate women's attire for
the sake of funny uh and mocking so
absolutely anybody can do it and
everybody on some level may have flirted
with it
okay but a lot of the time that people
that I've seen are called out for this
it's not that they were making fun or
mocking in some way it was just that
they had adopted
a fashion or a style or whatever I would
say that's a performance so if
somebody's culture and somebody's
identity becomes a performance then it's
reductive so if you're reducing for
example say the Civil Rights Movement to
an afro and you wear that or you wear
dreadlock wigs you know that
Rastafarians May wear you do that
because it's edgy because it's cool but
ultimately because it's not you and
you're getting some kind of cultural
capital from that by doing it and and
who's hurt by that well it's not a
matter of who's hurt by it it's who's
being disrespected by it well who's
being disrespected by the whole culture
of people whose identities are wrapped
in whatever you're dressing into and can
then take off of all you don't agree I
don't no so really put those on the same
level I absolutely racism and sexism
they're on the same level as cultural
appropriation that's exactly so if
somebody wears their hair like you're
wearing it you put that on the same
level as as racism absolutely I put that
on the same level as white supremacy
because white supremacy is
intersectional
uh guys sorry I think one of our Clips
got a little crossed up there I'll see
if we can possibly get it but Amela had
a wonderful response to that I'll make
sure we post it uh separately
um but in essence what you're getting
there is a professor I mean this man is
a professor at Arizona State everything
that he said there is complete nonsense
except it's nonsense that has now been
wholly imported into the Democrat Party
there are no Democrats except maybe for
Bill Maher
and a small Cadre of other people who
are willing to fight that nonsense you
can wear whatever haircut you want you
can make whatever jokes you want you can
eat whatever food you want you can put
on whatever clothes you want to put on
these people don't own you they don't
own your mind they don't know whether
you're doing something to honor it or
make fun of it and guess what you're
also allowed to make fun of things we
used to joke about everything we've got
you guys remember Don Rickles remember
Don Rickles who would literally walk out
into an audience and talk about the
[ __ ] and the Jew and the black guy
and the Latino and make fun of
absolutely everybody and then everybody
was like oh we're all part of America
we're all in on the joke as opposed to
oh well I can't make fun of you over
there because you will you you might
blow yourself up or something it's it's
it's so dangerous what these people are
pushing
um are we gonna be able to snag an
omelet thing you think no all right
we're gonna we're gonna put something up
separately on that because she really
just gave an absolutely wonderful uh
rebuttal to that guy uh but the point of
the clip really was to show that
everything he said there that is the
stuff that Kamala Harris believes that
is the stuff that the progressives
believe and this is why they Pander to
everybody because none of it really
makes sense but you just have to keep
people thinking that if someone wears a
haircut of a certain way or eats a
certain food that they're the bad guy
and you're the good guy but if you want
to see some true pandering we've got a
little collection of Democrats pandering
I remember Joe Biden this is Miami when
he was running for president
I just have one thing to say
all right
there you go come on
so you see what he did there he was
talking to Latino people so he pretended
that he liked despacito can I tell you a
funny story about despacito last year or
two years ago when we were off the grid
we went to Mexico we're at this Resort
and they just kept playing despacito
over it was every third song despacito
despacito you guys David is very calm
and cool like he does not get upset he
almost had a nervous breakdown he almost
killed an attendant because we couldn't
hear despacito anymore he turned against
Bieber anyway this is what they do oh
you're Latino people you must love this
Spanish song but it could be worse than
that you may remember Hillary in the hot
sauce what's something that you always
carry with you hot sauce
hot sauce in my bag swag that's us
really yes now listen I just want you to
know people are going to see this and
say okay she's pandering the black
people
okay is it working yeah
oh I forgot about that last line there
you're pandering to black people is it
working ugh God she's evil evil evil
evil but I know you're watching this and
you're going Dave this is too
heavy-handed you're showing me an old
video of despacito with the elderly man
you're showing me an old video of
Hillary Clinton with her hot sauce it
can't be that anything happened in the
last day like say yesterday and so I uh
I uh was sort of raised in the Puerto
Rican community at home politically and
so we and we came here for a long time
uh both for business and pleasure since
you're part of the third Circuit Court
of Appeals and Delaware is as well and I
was chairman of Judiciary Committee I
spent a lot of time in the northern part
of the state nothing it's meaningless
dribble every word that comes out of his
mouth yes he was raised in the Puerto
Rican Community politically what does
that mean it means absolutely nothing I
actually do want to throw back to it
it's only 10 seconds because look at
Jill Biden this this woman who I you
know she's worse than him because she
knows what's going on and she's abusing
him and using him and all of that stuff
and she's probably banging Gavin Newsom
on the side
um they're a little breaking news for
you but look at her face the entire time
because she knows everything he says is
nonsense she knows he can't read the
teleprompter correctly and she knows
he's always one breath away from the
entire thing breaking down look at the
soulless look at her face and so I uh I
uh was sort of raised in the Puerto
Rican community at home politically and
so we and we came here for a long time
uh both for business and pleasure since
you're part of the third Circuit Court
of Appeals and Delaware as well and I
was chairman of Judiciary Committee
Jill Dr Jill paging Dr Jill Jesus uh but
there's more if you want to see just the
endless woke nonsense from these people
here's Biden at a Hispanic heritage
event uh from Davis from a day or two
ago
[Applause]
dreamers can you imagine maybe some of
you were dreamers
it's like I don't know what people
expect to say when your mom's taking
your cross to Rio Grande and say no Mom
I'm staying here I'm not going I'm going
to make my choice come on this is
bizarre
the temporary status holders Farm
Workers and essential workers as well
okay I'm not even sure what his point
was there it was something about the
fact that you know the dreamers are the
kids who come from illegal immigrants
that are here something like that they
wouldn't want to say that they don't
want to come he's just everything with
these people it's just the worst sort of
pandering and uh let's just
how did this guy become president what
what did we do to deserve this what did
we do
um all right so what do we do here what
do we do well we clearly explain
ourselves as I often say to you guys and
we start voting a different way we
really have to start voting a different
way and that is happening right now uh
we've got some video here of Latino
people latinx people as they call them
in Texas explaining why they're leaving
the Democratic party she wants the party
to take stronger action on issues like
abortion and voting rights but our poll
found that the top issues for Latinos
was actually the cost of living we see
that prices are through the roof and we
want to know what people are going to do
to help put that burden down in
conservative stronghold States like
Texas signs of a political shift among
Latino voters with more now leading
Republican Maria
you
were a Democrat and you are now a
republican why because the the fact that
the Democratic party has changed a lot
and identif identify more with the
Republican party what things
well we're for God country family and
hard work
God country family and hard work pretty
good even if we all disagree on what the
exact definition of God is but that we
could all maybe agree that there's
something else going on and country's
pretty good and hard work is pretty good
meritocracy is good uh borders are good
so you're not going to believe this but
Latino people are like everybody else
and they care about the same things we
all do but that's why the media is
always trying to Latino people vote this
Ryan black people vote this way
these people vote this way because if
they can keep you in that box you're not
a fully functioning human being you're
just a cog in the machine but here's a
Latino NBC reporter admitting the Dems
are screwed Latinos are the largest the
fastest growing group of Voters and the
numbers are there we Latino voters
represent make up about one out of ten
voters but
they are also very unhappy I mean the
pandemic hit them very hard the economy
is hitting them very hard inflation is
hitting they are unhappy about the job
quality and if you see the the main
issues Latino care about yeah they are
right their economy the job quality so
um yeah this is a concern and this can
make things very difficult for Democrats
yeah Latinos once again they're just
like
they're just like all of us you know
they care about jobs they didn't want to
be locked down all of that stuff they
actually want borders
once you see it guys you just see right
through it so either
this is for that little sliver right I'm
always talking about that sliver of
people that actually could shift right
because you got your your sort of base
on both sides you got your base on the
right you got your bass on left but that
sliver of people that are the ones that
are still undecided or actually could
vote a different way or whatever it's
like this is what we have to illuminate
for them you can be part of the party of
racism and you can be part of the party
of high taxes and no borders and
chopping off children's genitals that's
a set of ideas that's you know you can
go for that or you could maybe be for
say hard work in the Constitution and
borders and then you know going hey I'm
going to put myself out there and see
what happens because we have equality in
this country not Equity so a little bit
of it is on me so that I could do that
uh what was that thing that Pursuit of
Happiness thing right because they wrote
that one down too and that was pretty
good all right we got a couple comments
from the locals Community Dragon says
they don't follow science they have
created a false religion out of
scientists ISM most dangerous yeah
absolutely I mean the same people who
will tell you follow the science and be
injected with things that are untested
and uh stay six feet away from people
and wear masks that don't work they will
are the same people I mean it's so
extraordinary those are the exact same
people who will tell you that an
eight-month fetus is not a life those
are
the same people who will virtually lie
about everything I mean they will tell
you that just because you have a penis
you're not a boy there is almost nothing
the fact that that even needs to be said
just so stupid thatch says Democrats
scream about all the things that Maga
Republicans will do to us but I'm
looking at all the things that Democrats
have already done to us that's a great
Point that's a great point and an
excellent use of caps right there uh
yeah it's as simple as that they keep
scaring us if these people get power
this is what they're going to do well
the truth is Donald Trump was president
and we had those four years and if it
wasn't for covet and then the Summer of
Love where Democrats rampaged through
the streets burning down cities uh if it
wasn't for that everything was really
good the economy was chuggling along we
had peace deals in the Middle East we
didn't have a war in Russia and Ukraine
like things were really really good and
I would venture to say that secretly
even some of the Trump deranged people
if they could go and turn back the clock
and be like you know what how about we
just roll back to say I don't know
winter of 2019 right winner winner of
2019. could we just go back there and
just all kind of take a breath and be
like like all right maybe orange man
isn't Hitler this thing's going pretty
well as opposed to what's happening now
with gas prices with a looming nuclear
war literally like you think that maybe
people should regret going all in on
destroying the guy you think uh Anka
says I remember Equity when I lived in
communist Poland in our block of flats
we had professors janitors drivers and
doctors we all have the same flats and
furniture and no motivation to work oh I
love that thank you for sharing that
comment I mean that's what it is that's
what it is do you want to all end up in
the same place why is it that when you
look back on like soviet-era communism
that the all of the buildings look
exactly the same with the weird green
lighting and there's no innovation
there's nothing interesting to look at
like that's a visual representation of
what communism does to the human Spirit
we'll all end up in our box with the
linoleum floor and the rattly
air conditioner or heater right none of
us whether you are a doctor who studies
for years will be able to succeed in a
real way and really follow your dreams
we will all just be little cogs in a you
know much bigger machine well it ain't
for me and I don't think it it ain't for
most of you so this is what we have to
fight because the vice president of the
United States regardless of whether the
New York Times and Reuters and
politifacts and the rest of them will
admit it she full on came out and said
that government assistance should be
based on skin color
and that we should be trying to get
everyone to that same spot and you know
what that same spot is exactly what you
just described right there from
communist Poland it doesn't matter how
hard you work what really matters is
we're just going to make you live like
that and by the way the elites will
always live way better than that when
Bill Gates is pushing you know stop
eating meat on people Bill Gates owns
more Farmland than anyone else in the
United States right now they lie they
lie they lie and they lie guys if you
haven't subscribed join us at rumble.com
reubenreport if you want to play along
during the show and see some pictures of
the babies and all that good stuff you
can join us at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
uh newest interview with Dennis Prager
all about uh the Bible and some old
ideas that are way better than today's
new woke ideas is up right now uh
tomorrow is Yom Kippur which is the
holiest day in the Jewish year so I will
not be working tomorrow gonna fast eat
some bagels at night a little repenting
the whole thing and then on Thursday uh
our second child we are inducing this
surrogate is going to be induced she's
basically at 40 weeks already so we are
going to be inducing so baby two will be
coming so there will be no show tomorrow
however Thursday we are going to do a
pre-taped q a which we're taping today
we'll air that on Thursday and then
there won't be a show on Friday right no
show on Friday I need like a day you
know with the kid and the screaming and
the crying and the pooping and it's a
lot you know what I'm saying uh and
finally before I go I will be on Megan
Kelly's show today at noon Eastern on
Sirius XM if you want to tune into that
and finally we leave you with a cold
close from the elderly man pretending to
be president
22.
get ready pal you're gonna end for a
problem
now we look
at 22.
I want to tell my Republican friend and
get ready Val you're going in for a
problem